- [Man] This program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what learn?
Visit our website or follow us on Facebook
and Twitter to keep up with
the latest UCTV programs.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler of
the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Ralph J. Cicerone,
who is the president of the
National Academy of Sciences
and chair of the National
Research Council.
His research in atmospheric
chemistry, climate change,
and energy has involved
him in shaping science
and environmental policy
at the highest levels,
nationally and internationally.
Dr. Cicerone served as
chancellor of UC Irvine
from 1998 to 2005.
He is the 2016 Hitchcock
lecturer at Berkeley.
Dr. Cicerone, welcome to our program.
- Thanks and good morning.
- Where were you born and raised?
- Western Pennsylvania,
a little city called New
Castle, Pennsylvania.
I stayed there till I
was about 18 years old.
- And looking back, how
do you think your parents
shaped your thinking about the world?
- It was a close family.
Not worldly in that sense.
It was a close family,
second generation of Italian immigrants,
so there tended to be an
extended nuclear family.
Very warm, lots of
wonderful aunts and uncles.
I would say family-centered.
So not much thinking about
the outside world actually.
- And when did you get the science bug?
In high school or earlier
or was it later in college?
- It was later.
I was not a, I guess what
you'd call a science fair
kind of a kid.
I didn't do that kind of thing.
I was all about sports, athletics,
anything that was in
season that's what I did.
The school was not very challenging,
the schools where I went.
So I was able to make it through
without too much studying.
- And you were a baseball player,
back then or was it later?
- Both, both and football
and basketball and golf.
Just anything that was in season.
So that's what I loved and
it wasn't till I went away
to college that I learned at all about
what it was like to learn
and what college meant.
Even later than that I began
to hear about graduate degrees,
which I had no inkling of what they were.
- And looking back, what
do you think you learned
from sports that may have impacted
your later career in science?
- I think quite a bit.
Assessing one's owns
strengths and weaknesses
and realizing that you can
compensate for some of those
with teammates and help each other out.
Then, I'm making this up now but,
just thinking back, the
idea of meeting challenges
and that it's not always gonna be easy.
That was good for me to learn. (laughs)
- And then you went to MIT?
- I did.
- And at MIT what did you major in?
- Electrical engineering.
It wasn't what I started out thinking,
but at the time, electrical
engineering was just
very, a sweeping kind
of a subject involving
mathematics and physics
and it had a reputation
for being hard and that it was important.
It was attracting students
left and right at MIT.
So I didn't really know what I was doing.
I had a little bit of
interest in chemistry,
but I didn't like the first
year's chemistry at all.
So I just moved immediately
into electrical engineering,
which so many other students were doing.
It turned out to be
exciting and challenging
and I had a hard time at first.
I wasn't very well prepared.
- But then you went on to graduate school
at the University of Illinois.
Undergraduate work was at MIT.
So when did the change to
climate studies begin and why?
Why did you move from
one field to the other?
- That came much later.
I didn't have much of a plan.
I didn't know what careers meant.
I went to college to be able to get a job.
Western Pennsylvania,
when I grew up and still,
has a lot of unemployment,
a lot of instability.
So my idea of going to college
that no one in my family
had ever gone to college before.
So I didn't know what I was
doing and I thought it was
all about being employable.
So going into engineering in
the wake of the Sputnik flights
seems like a national priority
and a way to get a job
so that's what I did.
It wasn't until, I think a
required research project
in my senior year at MIT,
that I began to see that
there were other things
than just textbooks and
learning what somebody put
in front of you but a
more open ended challenge
of doing research.
I really liked it.
I spent so much time on
my senior research project
and I probably really didn't achieve much,
but I thought it did, it was fun.
- When did you undertake climate studies?
Was in late in graduate school?
- Way after that.
I finished a PhD in electrical engineering
and the physics of
plasmas and got interested
or was assigned to work
on the earth's ionosphere.
You know, you and I may look
old to some of our viewers,
but this wasn't that long ago.
But the world was different.
To communicate, let's say,
from the United States to
Australia around the world,
we didn't have communications
satellites catching
these signals and relaying them.
We had to shine beams
of radio transmission and reflect them
off of the ionosphere, which
is a natural feature of nature,
ionized gas and through those reflections
community around the world, for example.
So this was important stuff,
commercially and even for the military.
So it was an exciting
field and I began to learn
that a little bit about
the earth using these
electromagnetic pulses
of energy, radio waves,
to communicate around
the world and also to
study this layer of ionized
material around the earth.
That began to get me interested
in where the atmosphere
came from, where does this
air come that we breathe,
how does it remain so stable and so forth.
Probably over the next
15 years I inched my way
to climate change but I went
through the ozone layer.
(laughs)
- I like to ask my guests...
We'll get back to your
research in a minute,
what they see as the skills
and temperament required
for doing what they do.
So, to be a scientist,
how would you advise
or how should students think
about the skills they need
and the temperament to
do the work of science?
- Well, the wisest advice
that everybody always says
is that you have to be as well prepared
by learning the fundamentals
of serious subjects
like mathematics and physics
and chemistry and so forth
and then by being prepared
you might be able to make
a leap that's based more on
intuition or imagination.
I'm not sure I agree with that.
I think a little bit of
everything is needed.
Certainly some preparation and
doing well in one's studies
but it's very different
to study out of a book
and to pass an examination,
whether the examination
is a test of what you've learned
or your readiness to move
on to something else.
That's very different from
doing research, in my view.
To step out into something
new without anything
to rely on is very different than it is
to simply reproduce something
that's already been done.
But both skills are needed,
so it's really a beautiful
pursuit, I think,
because once again, you
realize that different human
qualities and attributes are needed.
Perseverance is almost always required,
because you make mistakes.
Instead of just kicking yourself
you have to hang in there.
So perseverance is important.
Preparation.
There's two P's.
I don't know what the third P would be.
But I think incentive is really important,
being interested in something.
- Curiosity is important
because at one point
I read where you said that you
moved into climate sciences
because you thought
there were a lot of interesting
problems and discoveries
to be made.
- Yes and that was the
case when I first started
the research on the ozone layer too.
So little was known that when
we finally plunged into it,
we were able to make some
discoveries and some movement
forward because so little was known.
So that's another thing
there are, perhaps,
two kinds of people who do this work.
One is the type who wants
to be able to start off
in a library and read all
the background and what has
been tried, what has not
been tried and so forth
before moving forward.
The other kind is perhaps more cavalier.
Just jump into the
unknown and learn things
in kind of a back filling way.
Again, I think both kinds
of people are valuable.
- To be the second kind, you
really have to be comfortable
with yourself and able
to deal with uncertainty
and criticism.
- And maybe over confidence.
Over confidence, right.
Because as you know from what
we all know about history
of any endeavor,
so many of the ideas that we think are new
turn out be old ideas and
if we just would have taken
the time to look into the history,
we would have known that.
But it's really fun to discover
something for yourself,
even if it's not new.
Even if you find out later
that you did something
that other people have already done,
but you did it yourself
with nobody telling you
how to do it, that's fun.
- A lot of times, you're
doing things that,
in other words, calls into
question what your colleagues
have been saying about a
particular subject matter.
- Well that's true, even
today in scientific research.
A scientist doesn't become respected
and the object of other
people's trying to imitate
if he or she simply repeats
what other people have done
and gets the same answers.
It's the breakthroughs
that show that something
has been missing or that
there's an important connection
that hasn't been made or a consequence.
So that's what we all try
and it's pretty competitive.
- I think I read somewhere
that you talked about,
what did you call it?
You called it the combination
of freedom and responsibility.
So that in a way, you're asking a question
but it has to be tested
against the facts and reality
and that's very important.
- I think this is one of
the biggest breakthroughs
in human pursuits of all kinds
the last several hundred
years, to be able to measure
something and compare with a reality
and that science really should have
some predictive capability as well.
So when we think about
theories and implications,
we should be able to generate a prediction
that can then be verified or falsified.
That's how we make progress.
But it doesn't always
have to be so formal.
Sometimes it's just a random walk.
- You make the point that
the beauty of science,
you touched on it a minute ago,
is that it's self correcting.
It's a system that where you
wind up correcting yourself
based on the facts because
of the question you've asked,
but also your colleagues
and people working in the field will also
be a test for you of the
validity of what you're saying.
- And that's what makes
science progressive.
But from a broader societal point of view,
that self correcting attribute of science
is really important.
Sometimes we make mistakes,
but if it's an important
area, for example a medical matter
that has wide attention
people who are suffering
who are looking at the implications,
something important like that
with commercial applications
or security or
environmental, things like this,
anything that attracts
attention and if it's in error,
it will be caught very soon.
So for example, the times
when people try to falsify
anything in science,
they're really very limited
because the odds are if
it's anything important
you're gonna get caught quickly.
But of course the most
common type of error
is one that was unintentional.
It could be because of
biases or it could because
just of a bad experiment
that wasn't done right.
But that self correcting
attribute of science
is really important from
a human point of view.
- When you think of science,
you think of maybe mistakenly,
of somebody alone in a lab working away,
but one of the interesting
things for you is
that it's not just doing the science,
the pure science and getting it right,
but also the implications
of that science for the way
we live in our environment.
Talk a little about that
because that seems to have been
an important factor in
your motivations about
what you studied.
- For me, yes.
Not for everybody.
There are some rare very
important scientists,
whether they be economists
or mathematicians
or physicists, who focus on
a deep implication or some new
kind of test or measurement
that can be made that no one
else has ever done before
and no one else is interested in it.
That kind of individual
progress is absolutely stunning
and it's necessary.
Many other projects though,
do require group participation
and complimentary capabilities
that we can teach each other
but in the end, there may be
a group of people over there
who are doing part of the
experiment that you and I
would never understand
but yet we need them.
But the awareness of
implications, for example,
societal or human, for
let's say the sustainability
of the planet or whether
it's an economic consequence,
this also drives a lot of scientists.
To know that after all
those years of studying
and mastering a subject
they can now apply it
in some way that will have real
implications on real people.
Even there though, you have
this bifurcation again.
You can do an experiment in a laboratory,
let's say in biology,
that could understand a universal truth
that effects all organisms,
even though you weren't
interested in the implications at all
but it can still have these
sweeping implications.
Being aware of all these
implications though
is really important.
- Talk a little about
creativity in science,
because you're going down
on a course, you've identified a problem,
you're observing, getting
the data to disprove it,
or prove what you're assuming.
But then there's that eureka
moment when you see something
and open up a field.
Talk a little about that.
- That's really fun.
It doesn't happen to
most of us very often,
but when it does, it's
very self reinforcing.
I think part of it comes out
of self criticism though.
I remember in graduate
school toward the end of my
PhD work, I heard that one professor had
a kind of a metric or a
criterion, it was a man,
that he used evaluating students.
When the student began
to be able to detect
his own errors,
and he was that self critical
that he could find out
his own mistakes before
someone else pointed them out,
that was a sign that he or
she was ready to get a PhD.
That registered on me
and I think it's true.
Being self critical so that
you don't make erroneous
discoveries and you can always
check what you're doing
as go along and say,
"Gee, I'm really into something new now
and it's not because I've made mistakes,
but because I've checked my
progress all the way through
and I've arrived at a
point that no one else
has ever seen before."
That's the light goes
off and it's really fun.
- Does part of that come,
that self criticism,
come from the universe you're embedded in,
that is you're anticipating
the criticism that
your colleagues will make?
- Yes, yes.
Like most endeavors,
it's pretty competitive.
So and we're also educated and trained,
as upcoming scientists,
to not make mistakes.
We don't want to mislead people.
We want to be right.
We want to show that the
measurement is really accurate
and that if it's off a
little bit it's not too far.
So this is deeply ingrained
in us to not make mistakes.
There is some caution also
when a scientist makes
a truly big discovery that everybody wants
to pay attention to,
newspapers and interviewers
and so forth, there's
an element of jealousy.
Maybe even some suspicion
if the same person,
his face is out there all the
time claiming something new
and how important it is,
the competitors get a little tired of that
and they want to make
darn sure that this person
who's maybe bragging, maybe posturing,
maybe announcing something important,
but very sure he's right.
We don't want any false posturing.
- Let's now go back to your early work,
because you did some early
work that was very important
on the ozone layer and the
effect of chlorine gases.
Talk a little about that
and how you got into that.
- Well, I was trying to switch fields,
to switch my area of emphasis
from these ionized gases
around the Earth to something
that was more relevant,
more related to day to day existence
or at least life processes and so forth.
In those days, we didn't know
much about the ozone layer
but it was starting to
become clear that it was part
of the Earth's environmental
stability system.
In this case the natural
ozone layer absorbs
ultraviolet light that
comes out of the sun
and if it weren't for the ozone layer,
that ultraviolet light
would reach the surface
where it can break up
proteins in your skin,
cause skin cancer amongst
light skinned people
and damage plants and so forth.
So we knew that it was important
but we really didn't know
what was controlling it.
It's like you're trying
to create a budget.
How much of it is produced and
how much of it is destroyed.
So somebody here at
Berkeley, Harold Johnston,
had helped to work out how a special kind
of chemical process called catalysis
involving nitrogen oxides,
was helping to counterbalance
the natural production of ozone.
So my colleague and I just
went looking for other
chemistry that could be
important that would be
connected to all of that.
We stumbled on the idea
that the chemical element
chlorine could destroy ozone
under the right circumstances.
So we started researching
it and going back through
old laboratory studies
and made this proposal.
It was original, it was good.
It turned out to be right but
we missed the most important
part of it.
The most important part was
that humans were already
involving some chlorine
compounds in their daily lives
and commerce that were already
damaging the ozone layer.
These chlorofluorocarbon
gases in aerosol spray cans
and refrigerators, that
turned out to be the important
discovery by someone who had just finished
Berkeley grad school,
actually, Mario Molina
and his colleague Sherry Roland.
This set of discoveries
really opened up a lot of new
research that many many of
us knew that it was important
to get to the bottom of
this whole phenomenon.
How much more growth in that
industry could be accommodated
by Earth's natural healing
processes versus when we
would go past a tipping
point and cause a breakdown
in the ozone layer of some kind.
So for the next...
Gee, people are still
working on these issues
and it's led to international
agreements that were
remarkably successful.
- Talk a little about the
evolution of the field
of climate studies.
When you started in people
had been working on this,
but the field really
took off as you became
interested in the subject matter yourself.
- Well, it was probably the opposite,
that I became more and
more involved because I saw
that the field was taking
off in the sense that it was
getting to look important.
This was years and years
and years before the public
was aware of it, but we
began to see data coming in
that suggested that climate
change was going to occur
ever more rapidly.
It was much the same set of
notions and scientific input
that got me involved in the ozone layer.
In this case, the notion
is that human activities
are on a large enough scale
and of a particular type,
that they can effect the entire
global physical environment.
Not just dirtying our own
nest with air pollution
in one city,
but causing very stable
chemicals to spread all through
the global atmosphere that can then
leverage the entire Earth's energy budget
and change the climate.
This had become clear
conceptually and all the pieces
that we could evaluate
looked pretty solid.
Today, in 2016, of course
people are digging more and more
deeply into the details to figure out
what are the detailed implications
for regional, geographically
regional climates,
what's the time scale going
to be, sea level rise.
All of those possibilities
were alive back in the
early '80s, late '70s,
but awful lot of exploration
remains to be done.
- In addition to being a leader
in this particular field,
you've been someone who's
led in the organization
of the settings in which
this kind of research
could occur.
You came to UC Irvine and helped establish
an interdisciplinary department
there in geosciences.
Talk a little about that, I mean,
because that's a different
kind of science leadership
that is very important as
more and more resources
have to be made available
to take an even broader
and deeper picture of what's going on.
- Yeah and this is one of
the few times in my career
where I've actually planned something.
Usually I just let things happen
and do what I'm interested in.
But in that case,
I had seen these two powerful
examples of human activities
capable of effecting the entire planet.
Not necessarily in a limited way.
It wasn't clear that
things could remain stable.
I began to think, you know, we need a
better way that those of us involved
can learn the other
components of the actions
so that we don't make a
bunch of stupid mistakes,
but also begin to educate
the next generation
of young people.
I was pretty young at the
time, so I'm not saying that
we were focusing on teenagers.
I waited to see what would
happen around the world's
universities, say how are
universities going to respond
and I wasn't seeing much action.
So when I heard about
and opportunity to start
a completely new approach
in a graduate program
at one of the UC campuses, Irvine,
I looked into at first and
I volunteered to help them
to plan the program.
But after a couple of visits
I began to realize, you know,
nothing else is going on
when I look around the world.
Everybody seems to be
waiting for somebody else
to make a move.
There were some disciplinary issues,
like should everybody had a PhD in physics
before they start this kind of work?
Should everybody have a
PhD in chemistry before
they start this kind of work?
Or could these concepts
be incorporated earlier?
So we entered that idea
of starting the program
as a bit of a risk, not
knowing exactly how to go,
but it's gone very well.
The driving notion was,
and I think the summary
of the mission of the program,
was to detect and quantify
large scale trends in the
environment like air and water
and land, to understand their causes
and to predict the future.
So we never used the words
physics or chemistry or biology.
We focused on the
phenomena with the premise
that human caused
disturbances are going to be
a serious part of the future.
On the other hand, we always
have to look for natural causes
so we can separate out
what humans are doing
from purely natural phenomena.
- It sounds like you're saying that
in terms of the field in
general, that lot was going on
in different discreet areas
and part of the task here
was go bring it all
together and train people
to take the next step.
- Yes, from an educational point of view,
what were the rudiments in understanding,
in this case the behavior of the Earth,
as a linked biological
and physical system,
then how is it going to
happen organizationally?
Where would the resources come from?
How could we make sure that our graduates
and the research in the
department were speaking
to the issues?
So a lot of things had to be done.
We had to talk to the federal
agencies in the United States
who support the research,
what kinds of facilities could be built,
was the University of
California faculty ready
for something like this?
But the idea caught on.
- What about technology?
I guess what is going on in
the course of this evolution is
that new ways of gathering data
become very important and
it opens up a whole new
perspective and a way to
validate the information
you're gathering.
- I think you're absolutely right.
In fact more than I expected.
I can look back just
over the last few years,
10 years, and see when
certain instruments,
certain technology were
proposed for development
that I didn't think would ever work.
They're now yielding
incredibly valuable data
on Earth's climate.
This is stunning.
The miniaturization of
devices, their stability,
the places they can look,
our ability to store data
and to handle the data
without causing errors in
the retrieval of information,
just like your handheld devices.
All of these things were unforeseen,
to be able to process so
much data without errors
and to be able to have the
satellite pick out your telephone
for your personal communication
from all the signals
without making any errors,
this is fascinating stuff.
- What did you learn from this experience
in essence organizing a new discipline,
a new interdisciplinary discipline
and then you moved on to being chancellor.
In other words, were
there surprises for you,
insights about leadership
that you didn't have
until you actually were doing it?
- Yes, again, you hit on a good point.
I didn't appreciate
the value of leadership
for most of my life.
Now I realize that with
the right circumstances,
a leader in a position
can make a big difference.
So it's a combination, obviously,
of balancing the interests
and capabilities of people
against what might be the task at hand.
But in many institutions,
leadership really does matter.
I began to learn that.
So in between,
I was dean of the college of
physical sciences for a while.
I was dealing with physics,
chemistry, mathematics
and this Earth system science
and learning what the
different pursuits were
and how the education of
students in the programs
could be effected by the others.
It was really important
and allowed me to make
better decisions when I
became chancellor, I think.
- When you left the
chancellorship you became
president of the National Academy
and chairman of the National Research.
So talk a little about that role
and the differences with
the other roles you've had.
- In the middle of the Civil
War in the United States,
the Congress and President Lincoln created
the National Academy of Sciences.
It's amazing to me, the
more I've learned about it,
that they did this because here you were
in the middle of this
brutal civil war with the
outcome not determined.
Whether there was going to be one country
that emerged or not,
they did two or three amazing
things in 1862 and 1863.
One of them was the creation of
the National Academy of
Sciences to help to lift
the future United States
of America to be on a par
with Europe scientifically,
by raising standards,
by organizing pursuits,
by helping to prioritize
resources and so forth.
But they also created the
Morrill Land-Grant Act,
which as you know, founded,
created some of the best
public universities in the United States
as we see them today
to permit higher education
to be more accessible
to a much larger number of people than was
and could go to these small
private universities in 1862.
These were amazing feats.
Well getting back to the
National Academy of Sciences,
the mission was not only to elevate
the standards and quality and
activity of American science,
but also to be available
to help the government.
So of all the world academies of sciences
in different countries,
as I've now learned,
ours is almost unique,
certainly distinctive,
that we have no direct payment
from the federal government.
They don't pay us to exist.
But they will ask us to do
projects that are important
in the public policy arena.
On a project by project basis,
we then do help the government
as a completely independent
analyst and advisor.
Sometimes the tasks that they give us
are kind of prosaic,
kind of everyday things.
Sometimes they're kind of
cosmic tasks that we have
to undertake but the
idea of the government
creating a body that, in some cases,
would have a almost decisive role
that would not be under the
control of the government,
that was really rather
bold of the United States
government to do in 1863.
We try to live up to it.
We try to be independent,
objective, nonpartisan.
Some of the requests are kind of strange.
We have to argue back and
forth with the government
what the focus should
be, but we try to play it
completely straight and
objectively and we produce
about 150 reports every
year on these topics.
- And how are you funded?
- Pretty much project by
project by parts of Congress
or different federal agencies.
Sometimes by private
foundations, philanthropy.
So it's a complicated mix.
- Now before you became president,
President Bush asked you to chair a report
on climate change.
What I'm curious about, were you surprised
by the politicization that
followed in the debate
about climate change,
not just from the report,
but just the general
setting of the way science
is viewed today because
of that politicization?
- Yes, we could talk about
that particular report
from 2001 maybe a little later.
But yes, the degree to which
this whole discussion about
Earth's climate change has
become politically partisan,
especially in the United States.
There are only one or two other countries
where it's become partisan.
But in the United States
it's terribly partisan.
I just don't even understand
how this has happened.
Not only is it unnecessary
and destructive,
but it's not even understandable,
because historically, for example,
the republicans have
been pretty supportive
of basic research in this country.
So to have so many of
them turn on this issue
and say that it's somehow
erroneous or even fraudulent
is just stunning to me.
I don't understand how it's happened.
- Is it because of the interest involved?
Because if you're talking
about cutting carbon
you're talking about the use of petroleum,
among other things.
- We could probably talk all
day on all of the reasons.
Some of them is that
the situation could lead
to a regulatory environment,
which is not favored
by many people in different industries.
It's inconvenient.
For example, fossil fuels,
liquid fuels like gasoline,
have a real advantage when you're trying
to create transportation.
We now know that that's not the only way
to fuel transportation.
Electricity, for example,
from renewable sources
can also fuel transportation.
But there's a convenience to
using what we've always had.
The availability of
coal has been a big part
of western civilization
for what, 150 or 200 years,
300 years and to suddenly you know,
turn our back on it is, I
think it leaves a lot of people
cold and I don't mean that
(laughs)
literally, I mean it figuratively.
So there's a lot of reasons
why you can look back
and say this issues has become partisan.
Certainly the way the
newspapers and many commentators
talk about climate change,
there might be one sentence
on the science and something
that's been measured,
and then the next 350 sentences
are about the politics
or competing interests.
So it's a tough issue.
- What about the...
Let's go back to the report that you did
before you were president.
What do you see as the main
contribution of that report,
the main insight?
- Well, it was structured...
The White House asked the
Academy to give them answers
to 12 or 13 questions.
Specific questions and
I'll mention one of them
to illustrate it.
So I was not asked to be
chairman by the White House.
The Academy usually decides those things.
They try to be very independent.
The previous president of the Academy,
who was from UC San Francisco actually,
I think chose me to be
the chairman of the study
and we had a very short timeframe.
We had something like five
weeks to not only gather,
focus on the questions, provide answers,
and to have the whole thing
anonymously peer reviewed
from people all over the country.
But one of the questions was
how reliable are these
international reviews
or assessments that have
been published now for
25 or 30 years, 25 years,
the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change,
which is a very very
comprehensive organization that goes into
every aspect of climate change,
involves scientists from
all over the worlds.
There is some government participation,
so some people have
been worried about that.
We were asked to say
to answer the question
for the White House, how
good are their assessments?
Are they biased?
Are they exaggerating or the opposite?
It was a very specific set
of questions they had us.
You know, what could we say
about future human health
impacts of climate change.
Rather specific questions.
So that's the way it was
couched and we delivered
in five weeks.
It turned out the President
Bush was trying to decide
what his government would
do with the Kyoto Protocol
that was trying to
stabilize Earth's climate
by dealing with the greenhouse gases.
So in the midst of our
working on that report,
his White House decided not to participate
in the Kyoto Protocol.
So I'm not sure our report
had the immediate impact
one way or another.
But certainly, the report
go the country's attention
that we said yes, there is climate change,
it's measurable, it's growing,
it's likely to grow much
bigger and so forth.
- The reaction to that
report and the climate
that we've described with regard to
partisan politicization
of our understanding
of what we should do about climate change,
that is in part, shaped
your goals has head
of the Academy.
I mean, in other words, because science
has in this environment,
not necessarily because
of anything it done,
some communication problems in making.
Shall we say that
the attack on climate change
has led to a questioning
of the legitimation
of scientific research.
What have you tried to
do about that in terms of
communicating broadly,
the kinds of things you've
been saying about science here?
- This is a very big set of issues.
Certainly climate change is involved,
but there are many other too.
Like the teaching of evolution,
biological evolution,
everything we've learned
about how central biological
evolution is to the way life works,
genetically modified crops,
the effectiveness of different
medical interventions.
You name it.
The communication with the general public,
people who are not
scientists, but who are aware
of trends and who want
to know what's going on,
this is just very important.
I don't remember how
many different scientists
have said it, but it's that
we live in a world now
that is just evermore
dependent on science and
technology to provide
everyday needs as well as
those of the next generation
and yet, we understand
less and less as a people
of where the resources are coming from,
how they're being manipulated,
how we deal with the waste and so forth.
We've got a kind of a separation
of the importance of the
subject and our dependence on it
with knowledge of it.
How do things really work?
What would happen if we lost the internet?
What would happen if we lose electricity?
So I think the communication
among scientists
and the general public
is evermore important
and yet it's getting harder.
Scientists are using more and more jargon
and specialized language
when they describe things.
It's partly because that's
the way science works.
The so-called reductionist method,
where we go deeper and deeper
into a narrow set of topics
to be able to understand
fundamentally what's going on
or how to make a new discovery,
that makes it harder to
communicate, not only across
scientific disciplines, but
with the general public.
So I've been putting a lot of time
into these communication issues.
How do we avoid just out
and out misunderstandings?
How do we help scientists to understand
the importance of communication,
how to do it better,
how not to exaggerate,
but also how to describe
the legitimate prospects
for fantastic advances but
without over promising.
These are really challenges
and I think important.
So I've been putting
a lot of time in them.
- Also, at stake here,
is making the data that is
gathered open to public sources
and among other things
and there's also the issue of the way
publications now have a
faster and faster tempo
and so we, so...
In other words, science in a way,
has to really think about these things
because it's effecting
its communication skills
by responding to technology,
the new way of publishing and so on.
- And there are practical
applications and implications too.
For example, some
environmental regulations
that are designed to
protect the public health,
people whose industries are being effected
or who are otherwise skeptical,
want to see all the data
on which these decisions
are being based and yet
the scientific journals
are trying to limit the
amount of space that's
being take because they're filling up.
New journals are being
created where these results
are being presented and everybody's trying
to save space, make the
articles easier to read,
but still make them understandable.
Then from a fundamental point of view,
one fundamental tenent
of science is to be able
to reproduce someone else's
experiment or calculation.
Well, if I do a calculation
and you're trying to check me
you know, did I do it right,
am I misleading people
unintentionally, you would
have to see all of the input
that went into my experiment
or my calculation.
So when I publish that result,
I have to provide you,
as the critic who wants to test things,
enough of the essential
information so that you can
reproduce or try to replicate it,
try to check whether it works.
If it does you can then move
on to whatever you want to do.
But if it doesn't, you
have to call me on it.
So that gives us all a responsibility
to provide all the necessary information,
all the necessary assumptions.
So this set of issues
has become a big one now,
not only in communication
but how to optimize
the whole enterprise
and to avoid instances
that might look like fraud
or misleading or somebody pursuing
a particular financial
advantage, something like this.
So there's a lot of action
in the scientific community
now to do this.
- How do you communicate these
new realities and the changes
in scientific behavior
without changing science
in a negative way?
- That's a great point
because some of the actions
that are underway now
to try to make the whole
enterprise more transparent.
That is to see through to the bottom line,
where did this stuff come from,
how reproducible is
it, how valuable is it,
is putting a crimp on certain practices
and the question is how necessary is it.
For example, there's some fields
where now there are
requirements in the journals
that when you write and publish
a new result, you are required
to produce just literally
everything that went into the calculation,
including if someone asks
access to your old lab notebooks
that are sitting in a hallway somewhere,
not just what you've published
but access to everything
so they can check everything.
This is hard because the
resources don't exist
for you to be able to catalog everything,
store them, make them
available to anybody who asks
from all over the world,
some of these things
are being proposed now
and some of them are frankly, impractical.
So we're trying to come up
with a balanced approach
that will balance the
legitimate need to know
the details with one's ability to store
all the information, for example.
Drug companies, there have
been some notable cases
in the last several years,
of companies that have their
own research laboratories
who are trying to decide whether,
for example, to proceed
with the costly development
of a particular drug.
So they do experiments
that try to check on what
the early ideas maybe that
came in from another country,
what they look like and
can they be substantiated.
In some cases, quite a few cases,
the researchers in a
pharmaceutical company
are unable to substantiate
what someone else
has already claimed,
so they have to decide
whether to continue to
develop the drug or not.
So far, what I think is some of the work
on medical development
involves such complex systems
that even the things you
put into the experiment
aren't quite the same as your
competitor may think it is,
so that a great deal of
preparatory work has to be done
to sort this out and it's adding cost.
We don't want to see more
cost added to the system.
- What would you like to see down the road
in terms of climate research?
You're very attuned to what's
going on in that field.
What do you think we
need to be looking at?
- Well two main things.
One is to continue the
observations of the important
things on the Earth.
The temperatures, the ocean currents,
the wind patterns,
the precipitation patterns
and the ice amounts and sea level.
Those are the key variables.
It turns out, to measure those things
requires a real commitment,
'cause you can't go out
and measure something once and say gee,
at 10 o'clock in the
morning the temperature was
something in Philadelphia, PA
and something different in San Francisco.
You need an enormous amount of data,
a number of observations and
they have to be continuous.
So it requires a commitment
and the technology
to measure things,
variables like temperature,
repeatedly in many places,
in a continuous way,
without any offsets.
If you bring a new thermometer in,
you better make darn sure
that it gets the same answer
as the previous thermometer
so that you're not just
introducing an offset.
The second thing is
looking forward, of course.
How do we make predictions
based on the current state
of all of these variables as we
figuratively light a
fire under the system?
That we keep adding
greenhouse gases that will
heat up the surface, how
does everything change
around the world in important regions?
It's not just averaging
over the whole planet,
but we have to be able to speak to
individual locations, London,
Sydney Australia, Moscow,
places like this, as
well as all the different
separate climates of the United States.
So looking forward, we
have to know how to process
all the data and do the
mathematical calculations.
It's a little bit similar
to weather prediction
with some notable differences.
So looking at what we have now,
we have to maintain these
continuous observations,
high quality, some of
them involve satellites
and then looking forward
more mathematical talent
and computer resources
just have to be maintained
so that we develop
our predictive skills better.
Otherwise, humans are
not going to know what
to expect or how to adapt to it.
- One final question,
what would you advise a student
to prepare for the future as a scientist
in whatever field?
- I'm pretty conservative there.
I think there's no substitute that's
dependable without
knowing the fundamentals,
say of mathematics,
but to assess the human
impacts of all of these changes
we're undergoing, clearly we need
university outputs of all kind.
People who understand
regional economic development,
history, languages, of course.
But on the science side,
a really solid grounding
in mathematics and physics and biology
is needed to take on these problems.
- Then finally,
do you think we'll get
agreements on some of these
climate change issues world wide?
- I do.
I've become a little more
optimistic in the last
several months.
I think, for example, the
political partisanship
in the United States is not gonna last.
I know enough people on the
side of the republicans who
understand that they don't want
the situation to become evermore partisan.
We can't expect any of our
politicians to really understand
all of this in detail.
I've learned that.
But they're smart people.
But of course, they don't
have the time or background
to understand things in detail,
so we're not waiting for that.
There are ways to attack
these problems by,
for example, more renewable
energy that's affordable
and reliable and transportable.
There are companies, in
fact young people working
in companies all around the world,
who are really refining solar energy
and storage of solar energy
and wind energy in remarkable ways.
Some of these technologies
are now competitive
even with low oil prices.
It's gonna take a while because the scale
of our energy infrastructure
around the world is so
imponderably large, it's gonna
take a while to replace it.
But I'm optimistic.
I think technology's helping a lot.
I think the general notion
that humans are causing a
global planetary problem,
that notion is growing,
especially amongst young people.
So I'm becoming more
optimistic and there is
a forerunner of an international agreement
that came out of Paris
in December of 2015,
which has some good potential to it.
- Well on that positive note Dr. Cicerone,
I want to thank you very much
for being on our program
and helping us understand
what science is all about.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.
(moody instrumental music)